buongiorno signori benvenuti a questo
nuovo video e finalmente siamo su un
gioco particolare perché come potete
vedere dalle barre aperte il sangue per
terra i cadaveri nei sacchi questo video
non potete guardarlo con la mamma ecco
il papa premi tab per la lista dei
giocatori ci sono solo io
perfetto meraviglioso gioco online per
giocare solo io cos'è sta roba varia
larga questa è mia madre che entra in
camera quando non mi alzo la mattina
anche in quarantena tra l'altro wake up
svegliati sempre mia madre dopo avervi
buttato fuori da casa con un calcio sei
stato scelto minchia l'interrogazione no
aspetti proprio uno studiato mi scusi mi
avete scelto per che cosa esattamente
io questo gioco è incredibile
teoricamente agli screen che ho visto
vorrei giocato perfetto credo che
abbiamo affondato la nave ii e trovai
dei cannoni aspettano nei sixties ma
quella era la mia nave e siamo approdati
su quest'isola qualcosa non va bene
cerca le provviste e beh sicuramente se
siamo parlati sull'isola e ci sono i
cadaveri nel menu per terra sicuramente
qualcosa è andato storto effettivamente
però devo capire ancora quel disco c'è
qualcuno buongiorno
beh almeno allegro lei mette che
comprende faccendini balzar mi scusi bel
ciapet non è un morto ce ne è uno zombie
ad evidenti bruttissimi mi spiace non
volevo farti da dentista però tanto
staccata sembra fatta in microsoft
ho trovato un'arma quanto scommettiamo
si alza quello saltato non c'è più quel
franco schiano franco lo dico io signor
franco mi scusi madonna che volta
madonna due ore per ammazzarne uno è
bello visto gioco genitori bresso e
milioni quindi potrebbe sempre mi scusi
comunque aprite le porte ragazzi mi
servono delle armi un pò più efficaci se
voglio provare a battere sta gente che
non è proprio facilissimo ti picchio col
femore porca vacca una femme orata in
bocca che male corriamo ragazzi perché
devo trovare assolutamente altre armi
chiudi la porta quanto non possono
entrare teoricamente eccola l'ho trovata
l'altra arma ama coltellaccio mi sento
che sussurrate vi sento che non usate
tanto verde anche ai a tema le mori
madonna è fortissimo suo coltello è
fortissimo
non ho capito bene come posso riparare
gli oggetti pre fortissimo ed è tutto a
posto qua oggi cucino io zuppa di
cadaveri tagliate male sta morendo
la madonna non aveva visto un cast
agente aiuto petardo dove la bomba l'ha
lanciata alla lanciata per terra non
l'annunciata lanciata sono morto aiuto è
caduto quello e che è svenuto jolo
giulia porta come si usano le robe degli
oggetti aiuto che sto morendo
a parte che non possono aprire porte
quindi che cosa mi sto preoccupando a
fare va beh possiamo uscire al suo
casinò spero di sì perché se no è una
tragedia
minchia piove ci mancava solo questo ma
che c'è un obiettivo da raggiungere non
ho capito quale è che quello di fare una
spada ho fatto climbing aspetta che non
so come usare la spada da spalla ecco
porco demonio vieni qua tracing si sa mi
chiamo mancato tagliate male
porca vacca
c'è la squadra che ha la stessa la
stessa distanza di di da.dd raggio
d'azione del coltello come avere un
coltello perché vorrei effettivamente
trovare delle armi decenti tipo un
cannone però va bene anche così mi scusi
mi scusi ha apposto siete veramente
brutti ragazzi fatevelo dire da
pannocchie e mo fare questo obiettivo
qua quale il discorso che c'è e può
trascinare cosa vuoi
cosa vuoi che faccia find a safe house
trova una casa sicura immagino sia
questa no non mi sembra sicurissimo
vabbè ai ragazzi troviamo il villaggio
vicino visto il 4 villaggetto vicino che
voi che non ci andiamo a controllare
sicuramente c'è gente buona e affidabile
ai quali affidare le mie granate che
sicuramente versano meglio mano loro
canale ma non mia ma un essere umano uno
in tutto sto bordello c'è buon salve mi
scusi
sto cercando un mio simile è difficile
trovare me ne rendo conto però almeno ci
si può provare un cacchio dovrei andare
ragazza in una di quelle città pazzesca
enormi vuoi vedere cosa che diavolo ci
trovo dove che posso andare stretch air
tipo c'è un castello prenda la striscia
che mi sembra la capitale vi sto casino
obiettivo cercare una cittadina
gigantesca vedere come messa sicuramente
bene la vedo just wright shira quello
che la vedo ben difficile da raggiungere
aspetta e uno scarico gli zombie brain
giorno
porca vacca ci piace questo però mi
scusi uomo di latta prenda questo io
regalo è tutto suo
ecco a posto
mica livello 8 fosse knight orco del
demonio
no ragazzi è fortissimo a thiene a
battaglia alla dark souls video lanciare
granate a profusione questo caso no
schiatta mai l'ho mancato pure giano
poche topi a te questa da regalo a theo
jotaro più a posto
lo spaccato un livello 8 ma avrà dato un
sacco di punti maggiori si è messo sei
ore
grazie forse era meglio non non andare
in città a quanto pare c'è gente troppo
livellata però è stato un bel
combattimento che tra lo questo era
nascosto in una capanna che non mi
rappresenta niente avenia vincita la
vediamo bello si può anche notare in
questo gioco mi sorprende un sacco
capitan a porta che cazzo è in acqua che
cacchio è rega mi chiami sono cagato
nelle mutande
ma che cazzo hai un attimo che mi sto
riprendendo all'infarto
mi sono pagato addosso un attimo a sto
ancora cercando una casa sicura in città
mio dio può invece c'è un altro
obiettivo groscavallo ok che questa news
tyson found buongiorno non essere umano
salve ei come stai
ma se in tema strolin d'ora term che
cazzo hai detto c'è un pitcher che in
italiano ragazzi e cappellano pietro va
bene cosa vuole che io faccia il
cappellano pietro vai al gate di fort
myer peccato ragazzi che non si possa
dormire perché avrei fatto passare la
notte quindi ci andiamo di notte per
forza l'unica bussola
andiamo alla porta di sta minkia cosa
non equa e quaggiù ok pesca sta andando
ok ho scalato il muro non so come ho
fatto come vorrei fare effettivamente in
tutti i giochi quando c'è un muro
lo vorrei scalare così e puntualmente
non riesco a farlo
madonna che crepi gente nel campo
orribile nomis scusate non fate caso i
fuochi d'artificio sono io che ho
sbagliato tasto allora map
ok ai vai vai se corri ancora un pò
chateau restifa dorival al al portone
devo dire al cappellano pietro che che
cosa succede al portone ma ci siamo
fuorché a vacca signori bere caro una
bomba jolo sono stesi 65 c'è un orda di
zombie madonna mi dispiace se riunisco e
parti orca vacca stavo scherzando e già
ancora aiuto allora parliamone
parliamone parliamone questo non è un
raduno dei one direction porca vacca
scherzavo ragazzi non insegnamento
arrivare dal cappellano pietro signor
pietro vada a fare in culo lei e su
questo brutto per cent anche successo
finita la musica di netto la quindi
niente poi sei rimasto solo tu attenti
posso anche ammazzare è finita come
finisce lordata finisce la musica
fantastico e poetico dunque cappellano
pietro devo riportarti la notizia
dell'orda arrivo mi scusi
i donatori survivor's guarda porca vacca
mi sa che note uccidi lorda e come
minchia dovrei ce l'hai un bazooka una
mini gang
perché se la vedo difficile per
concludere ragazzi per far vedere che
sono un temerario tornò nel lorda e
vediamo cosa ne pensano
effettivamente stavolta potrebbero
starli ad ascoltare visto che giorno
ogni giorno sono tutti più buoni
scusate signori posso giocare ma il
vostro party grazie aiuto
l'hack è male sono fatti fuori un
miliardo sono xena la principessa
guerriera adesso va bene questo gioco
incredibile comunque fantastico dove di
far esplorare poesia mi ha fatto
respirare qua era mica signori io e
pietro il cappellano pietro vi salutiamo
ringrazio aver visto il video ci hanno
proseguito di scrivere che non mi piace
era come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video pieno di orde di zombie che vi
seguono bella ragazza
[Musica]